[Music]
foreign good morning everyone nurses in
England are striking for a second day
today along with paramedics in Wales as
the wave of industrial action in the NHS
just keeps on growing Hospital leaders
are preparing for bigger coordinated
walkouts next month set to be the
largest strike in the history of the
Health Service after ambulance workers
voted to join nurses in a combined day
of action on the 6th of February
emergency 999 call workers also going on
strike that day shiman standing by for
us this morning hello to you shiman uh
Goodness Me 6th of February not a day to
be poorly is it
no it won't be especially say it will be
a huge day for industrial action today
we are expecting more nurses on the
picket line in central London it comes
as thousands of nurses across the
country and around 55 different NHS
tourists will be taking strike action
today and as you say on the 6th of
February that's when the third round of
strike action from nurses represented by
the Royal College of Nursing Union will
also be taking their strike action on
the same day as the GMB Union and that's
a union that has around 10 000 members
and it also represents ambulance workers
paramedics Emergency Care assistants and
call handlers they've announced that
they'll be striking on the 6th of
February along with nurses as well as on
the 20th of February March the 6th and
the 20th of March now yesterday we heard
from nurses about some of the reasons
why they have decided to join the picket
lines they were speaking about pay about
how their pay hasn't risen in line with
inflation and how them and their
colleagues are having to rely on things
like food banks to be able to get
through the month on top of that they're
speaking about staff shortages which is
making the job the day job hard and it's
also having a direct impact on patients
so these are some of the same issues
that ambulance workers are also
complaining about and this is causing a
huge concern for NHS managers we've
heard from saffron caudry who's the
chief exec for NHS providers
organization who said they're really
worried about this coordinated strike
action plan for February she said that
nobody in the NHS wants more strikes
including those on the picket line
urging ministers to get around the table
with unions to urgently deal with the
key issue of pay for this financial
month and of course the government have
spoken about negotiating with pay but
have refused so far to discuss this
different Financial year and this is
something that especially the nurses
unions won't bend on they're saying that
this Current financial year needs to be
addressed now there is room for
negotiation the government said that
they are open to talking with unions but
they say that so far the requests that
are being made by unions are unrealistic
and therefore they need to get around
the table to open up those discussions
again and until then there will be
further strike action throughout the
course of today and tomorrow and in
coming weeks okay Michael thanks very
much indeed Michael go for the
government today joining us live from
Blackpool we'll tell you why in just a
second first though Mr Gove good morning
to you let's talk about the strikes um
should we
um formal leveling up secretary Simon
Clark your predecessor criticized nurses
for not budgeting their finances
properly they need to use feed Banks
Jillian Keegan saying nurses only turn
to food backs when a relationship or a
boiler has broken down do you agree with
your cabinet colleagues that nurses are
excellent at saving lives but hopeless
with their finances
uh no I would never put it that way I
think we appreciate that nurses everyone
who's working on the front line in the
National Health Service is not only
doing an amazing job and
um Mike thanks and gratitude to nurses
uh uh today is something I want to
express very deeply and personally I
also think that when we're looking at
the uh the paid claims that are being
made but by people within the National
Health Service and also people in other
parts of the public sector we have to
balance uh making sure that we do
everything we can to reward them for
their hard work with recognizing that we
also have to be careful stewards of
public money overall and what we can't
do is uh necessarily exceed to every
demand in the public sector for pay
increases because uh we don't want to be
in a position where the Public Finance
is overall are out of control
yeah so your colleagues are wrong to
criticize the way nurses manage their
money
I would never criticize uh nurses for uh
uh something like that I think the most
important thing to do is to recognize
the people who are working in the NHS
are people who've dedicated their lives
to a caring profession they're doing
everything they can to support us
um I know myself in recent weeks having
seen the NHS uh close up front and
personal uh the dedicated care that
nurses and others who work in the
National Health Service give and of
course we want to do everything possible
in order to make sure that people are
paid well and in accordance with their
their skills and respecting their
commitment but we also have to balance
that against the need as I say to make
sure that uh that public funds are spent
wisely I hope that you're fully
recovered from having to use the
National Health Service previously and
that your health has recovered thank you
for sharing that with us and what about
this coordinated um strike action with
nurses ambulance workers and emergency
call handlers on the 6th of February how
responsible is it of those workers to
all strike on the same day
well naturally we wouldn't we would
prefer for the not to be any strikes at
all we prefer the not to be coordinated
strike action of this kind I just say
two things the first is that I'm
conscious that ambulance workers nurses
and others when they do go on strike
action and I don't approve of it I have
to say but they do take steps in order
to ensure that they can look after the
the most urgent emergency cases the
second thing that I would say is that we
are introducing legislation to make sure
that there is a minimum service level
that should provide people with peace of
mind that there will always be an NHS
there for them and indeed other blue
light services that they need it's just
unfortunate that other parties in the
House of Commons labor and the liberal
Democrats won't support that legislation
in order to make sure that there will be
a minimum level of service for everyone
you're in Blackpool today 40 million
pounds for a new carbon neutral
multiversity in Blackpool and people
can't afford what they're heating on in
Blackpool
um are you not are you going at it the
wrong way
no this is I think the fourth time I've
been in Blackpool this year and the
reason I'm here is that uh we want to
level up the whole country we want to
make sure that in areas like Blackpool
that have been overlooked and
undervalued in the past there's an
investment in the future so earlier this
year we invested 30 million pounds in
helping to regenerate the the very heart
of Blackpool to bring new job as an
investment here and today we're
announcing 40 million pounds for a new
uh higher education campus here
multiversity which will ensure that
young people in Blackpool get the sorts
of opportunities that young people in
the in the rest of the country have had
if we're going to make sure that people
get the the sort of high earning jobs
which will guarantee there and their
family's future we need to invest now in
education and nowhere is more important
than here in the northwest
yeah you say that but while running for
um prime minister in the summer a video
emerges as an eye prime minister
admitting he took money from deprived
areas to give it to other parts of the
country rather flies in the face of what
you've just said
well the proof actually is what the
Prime Minister was doing and what we're
doing today
um that's more than two billion pounds
being spent to more than 100 projects
across the United Kingdom and the areas
that are benefiting places like
Blackpool and Morecambe and cleethorpes
and Wigan these are areas which have
been overlooked in the past by previous
governments but this government is
absolutely committed to leveling up to
spreading opportunity and to investing
in the future and making sure that
people have uh whether it's investment
in higher education here or investment
in economic activity elsewhere the
opportunity to prosper in the future
yeah you were amiss not to mention
Richmond in that list as well I would
suggest of course the constituency of
the Prime Minister they're receiving 19
million pounds as part of this handing
out of cash our cash it's been described
as the Posh part of Yorkshire the Surrey
of the north and income deprivation down
to 22 as opposed to Blackpool where it's
60 one percent
well we are giving money to catrick but
that money is going to the uh the
biggest Army infantry base in the
country
um again over recent weeks I've had an
opportunity to talk to service families
about their accommodation I don't think
anyone would deny that investing money
in making sure that our service families
have absolutely the best circumstances
to support them I think anyone would
deny that is a good use of money and if
people want to say that service families
and that the catrick Garrison doesn't
deserve cash then let them
uh okay let me I'm sure they will let me
ask you about wig and you talked about
Wigan which of course is where your
opposite
um number resides representing the good
people of Wigan the leader of the
council 20 million quid or thereabouts
for hey Hall where I got married
actually
um the council say although we are
relieved to have received confirmation
of the funding for hey Hall our concerns
about the leveling up fund system remain
and we would continue to urge the
government to find a more appropriate
way to deliver the investment local
areas like ours deserve
well again you can't always necessarily
expect gratitude in politics but I do
think it is a good thing that we're
contributing millions of pounds uh to
Wigan
um the investment in Hay Hall is an
investment that the council itself
argued for and again the uh the
inference was from from the previous
question that some not UK but some would
be criticizing the money that's going to
catterick to help Army families
um this is money that is going to the
constituency as you quite rightly point
out of my opposite number labor MP Lisa
nandy so we have objective criteria that
govern where money is going we look at
the Strategic fit the deliverability the
economic benefits and Heritage matters
as well so that investment in Hegel is
an investment in wigan's future okay but
the announcement leaves out to a lot of
the more deep deprived areas in the UK
disproportionately benefiting
conservative areas I'm told of the 80
successful bids only half are in the 100
most deprived areas of the country
well there are areas of deprivation
across the whole United Kingdom I think
it is the case actually that more labor
local authorities than conservative
local authorities receive money but it
will be news to people in cleethorpes or
in workington who are receiving money
today that they're not areas of of uh of
of Holly need areas that have been
undervalued in the past
to talk to you as always thanks for
taking the time to join us in God's own
country this morning thank you thanks
Keith
thank you thank you program for you bye
still to come the program for you this
morning just after eight uh joined as
you heard by the shadow leveling up
secretary Lisa
thousands of nurses striking today
speaking to the Royal College of
nursing's General Secretary Pat Cullum
and as we enter deadline day for the
restoration of power sharing at Stormont
joined in the studio by Shin fan leader
Mary Lynn McDonald
before that though let's talk about New
Zealand's prime minister Jacinda adern
she has unexpectedly quit saying she
will step down next month and will not
contest this year's general election
fighting bacteria she said she no longer
has enough in the tank to do the job
Justice
I'm not leaving because it was hard
had that been the case I probably would
have departed two months into the job
I am leaving
because with such a privileged role
comes responsibility
the responsibility to know when you are
the right person to lead and also when
you are not
I know what this job takes and I know
that I no longer have enough in the tank
to do it justice
it's that simple
well Nicole's standing by for is in
Sydney with more this morning wow that
was a surprise wasn't it good morning
it was a surprise in speaking to new
zealanders they all say that they're
shocked by the news they had been
expecting that she would stay around for
the next election but clearly as we
heard from an emotional Jacinda ardern
she's exhausted she's been running the
country for five coming into six years
and during that long press conference
she said time and time again there's not
enough left in the tank and I'm only
human she also said that she wants to
marry her partner and she'd like to be
there for her daughter but time after
time there's been loads of crises in New
Zealand and not only the global pandemic
but also in 2019 we had the Christ
Church Massacre 51 people killed in New
Zealand gunned down in two mosques in
that City and that actually
elevated the status of Jacinda Arjun on
the international stage she was seen as
a caring compassionate leader empathetic
I was there during that period She
comforted new zealanders she wore the
head scarf and all of these images were
broadcast around the world and really
contributed to a lot of the sort of
myth-making around Jacinda ardern this
young female politician in a small
country of only five million people but
over the last few months her popularity
domestically has been waning as has the
popularity of her party the labor party
New Zealand is suffering the same
problems that the rest of the world has
an economic crisis Rising inflation
soaring house prices and a population
that's just sick of it really so there
was a lot of concern about how she would
lead the party coming up to this
election but for new zealanders they're
still very proud of the role that
Jacinda arjune played on the
international stage and she enabled that
country to punch above its weight
diplomatically okay for now thank you
thanks a lot Nicole let's talk about
King Charles he's asked for the prophets
from a billion pound a year Crown estate
wind farm deal to be used for The Wider
public good rather than his funding for
the monarchy
six new offshore wind energy lease
agreements announced by the crown estate
which usually bolster the monarchy's
official funding but the King has
surrendered the revenue more than 312
million pounds a year to the treasury
for the benefit of the nation's finances
deadline day once again for the
restoration of power sharing at Stormont
that means unless leaders are able to
strike a deal by midnight another
election
could be on the cards our senior Island
correspondent David Blevins is with us
now at Stormont
um this is Groundhog Day isn't it
yes okay wouldn't we be rich if we had
five Pines for every time they missed a
deadline to form a power sharing
government here at Stormwind and they're
going to do that again at midnight
tonight it means the Northern Ireland
secretary Chris Heaton Harris has 12
weeks in which to make up his mind
whether or not he's going to call
another election given that the campaign
would take about six weeks realistically
he has to decide by the beginning of
March and most people think he's going
to stall on that decision awaiting the
outcome of the ongoing negotiations
between the EU and the UK on that tricky
Northern Ireland protocol they seem to
be moving towards end game there they're
working hard on finding Technical
Solutions to the problems created by the
establishment of a trade Border in the
Irish sea between Great Britain and
Northern Ireland but of course it's
always important to remember that this
isn't just a technical problem it's also
a political problem and the big question
is can they find a compromise that will
be enough to persuade the Democratic
unionists to end their boycott of
Stormont and come back into the power
sharing executive here before the 25th
anniversary of the Good Friday agreement
in April will there be a government then
I wouldn't bet five pounds on it we're
chatting to Marilyn McDonald
um a little bit later on obviously
brexit very much going to come up
yes Mary Lou McDonald of course is a
woman who is Riding High in the polls in
the Republic of Ireland many people
think she could well be the next Irish
Prime Minister the next t-shirt and of
course her Deputy Michelle O'Neill is
currently first Minister designate in
Northern Ireland the first nationalist
to have been elected to that office so
if ever there was a moment when Shin
Fein might want to compromise with the
unionists in order to see the devolve
government back up and running it's
right now so it'll be interesting to
hear what Mary Lou McDonald has to say
about that and also what she has to say
about the new Irish Prime Minister Tisha
Cleo varadkar's approach to the
negotiations with the EU on the Northern
Ireland protocol can the Irish
government perhaps do something that
persuades the EU to soften its line
enough that will bring unionists back
into the power sharing government here
okay David I'll ask her thanks very much
indeed for now thank you
looking at some of today's other
headlines for you now and a hiker
reported as missing in Southern
California has been named as the British
actor Julian Sands who's 65 reported
missing in the San Gabriel mountains on
Friday he's known for his role in the
film a room with a view of course and
the TV series Dexter authorities say the
search of the actor will continue when
weather conditions improve
thousands of people from around Peru
have traveled to the capital in support
of the former president Pedro Castillo
who was ousted and arrested last year
after a failed attempt to avoid
impeachment 53 people have died in the
unrest since the new president you know
baluarte assumed office last month
foreign
are suspended today due to strike action
in France piano ferries have said
services will not run from 7am but are
expected to resume from 2PM the 24-hour
walkout is over the French government's
plan to raise the retirement age
police searching for a couple and a baby
say they must have lots of cash on them
as they've been living off grid for 11
days officers have been trying to track
down Constance Martin and Mark Gordon
who lost most of their belongings in a
car fire after she gave birth
Elon Musk has been described as a liar
in a Securities fraud case the Tesla
owner was in court over a number of
tweets he made about the company's
status in 2018. the Tweet syndicated
that mosque had secured the money to
take Tesla private which boosted its
stock but shareholders sued mosque after
learning the deal was not going to
happen
the New Mexico district attorney will
announce today whether the actor Alec
Baldwin or others will face criminal
charges over the fatal shooting on the
set of the movie rust in 2021
cinematographer Helena Hutchins was
killed when a gun Baldwin was using
during a rehearsal fired a live bullet
here's Martha with more
this represents a judgment day certainly
in terms of any potential criminal
Reckoning for Alec Baldwin and others in
connection with that shooting on the set
of the film rust I'm sure you'll
remember Helena Hutchins was a talented
Rising cinematographer also the mother
to a young son she was shot dead
accidentally by Alec Baldwin a bullet
that he shot traveling through her chest
and lodging in the shoulder of the
film's director Joel Souza who's made a
full recovery the Santa Fe District
Attorney's office has compiled a report
stretching to hundreds of pages about
that day and that incident that office
has now decided which individuals if any
will be charged with criminal offenses
in regards to Miss Hutchins death now
there are a number of individuals who
may be found criminally culpable
potentially one of those is of course
Alec Baldwin he admits uh Paul back the
hammer so the back part of the gun that
he didn't always pulling the trigger he
also denies having any knowledge of live
rounds live bullets on that set but he
also was one of the film's producers so
he very well could face criminal charges
and certainly some legal experts expect
that he will another of those that may
be considered for criminal charges is
the film's assistant director Dave halls
and he was inside that set when Helena
Hutchins was shot dead and he's alleged
to have been the individual who handed
the gun to Alec Baldwin another person
who may be charged is the film's armorer
Hannah Gutierrez read in her role she
was responsible for all weapons on the
set she was relatively young at the time
only 24 which some people find
remarkable given what huge
responsibility that role is on a film
set so those are just three individuals
who could face charges of course there
are other members of the production
staff and cast and crew but also could
face charges we'll find out via a
written statement from the Santa fe's
District Attorney's office around 4 P.M
today UK time
Sky News has traveled to taiwan's most
southern point to get a unique insight
into a potentially perilous standoff
playing out between China and the island
nation we met with former Navy radar
operator and radio Enthusiast Robin Sue
who used equipment to allow us to listen
in to fighter jet activity let's take a
listen
help me
hello Nan um who filmed that for us uh
Johnny is now from Taiwan hello to you
um Helena that's beautifully
illustrating if I might say so just the
sort of challenges that Taiwan is facing
from the air
that's exactly it it gives us a really
rare Glimpse and an insight into this
extremely serious standoff that goes on
above the ears of Taiwan and the Taiwan
Strait and you wouldn't think it this
looks like a paradise here in the
southern tip of Taiwan absolutely
beautiful part of the world but there is
a very serious standoff going on in the
skies almost every single day now Taiwan
of course a self-governing island that
China sees as its own and Chinese
fighter debts are now routinely almost
every single day Crossing What's called
the median line which is the unofficial
Maritime border between the two and when
that happens the Taiwanese Jets scramble
to intercept them and what we heard
there in that clip was a live real-time
communication between those two
militaries the Taiwanese voice you heard
there saying you're entering our
airspace essentially leave immediately
we heard some other recordings
um as well okay today that are really
very unusual we heard one from appeal
delay Air Force fighter pla the people's
Liberation Army the Chinese Army
essentially and it's actually
communicating with an American jet that
we think flew over this at the south of
Taiwan probably from the Japanese
Direction and that Chinese voice warning
the American jet to stay away from its
airspace saying leave immediately in
English actually interestingly as well
so it is a rare glimpse into this
standoff that's going on and it matters
because in my interview with taiwan's
foreign minister just yesterday he said
that the government really worry about
these activities because one misstep one
small mistake one accident and this
could quite easily spiral and escalate
into a very very serious conflict so a
very interesting little unusual look
into just how tense it can be okay for
now thanks so much indeed Helen and
thank you
Manchester Airport has temporarily
closed both of its runways due to heavy
snowfall the airport said health and
safety will always be its top priority
and that operations will resume at its
earliest opportunity runways at the
airport were also forced to close in
December last year due to poor weather
a number of Met Office weather warnings
are still in place across the UK as the
cold weather continues let's bring in
Joe with more we've seen Good morning
Joe we've seen what's been happening up
in Manchester today what about the rest
of us
morning
yeah there are some wintry showers
around bringing some snowfall there's
some winter showers across Wales
Northwest England we've seen that heavy
snow in Manchester and some across
Northern Ireland and into Northern parts
of Scotland as well and it's a freezing
start so as well as some snow in places
we're actually seeing icy stretches as
well so freezing starts across the
country down to minus eight degrees
Celsius last night in Scotland widely
down to -1 and -2 degrees Celsius across
the country so freezing start those icy
stretches and a risk of some snowfall
through the morning and there will be
further wintry showers as we go through
the course of the morning and through
the day and there are Met Office
warnings like you said we've seen those
warnings across northern and western
parts of Scotland for snow and ice also
Northern Ireland Northwest England and
Wales as well with a snow and ice
warning there valid until midday there's
also an ice warning across Southwest
England which is valid until 10 o'clock
this morning but like I say there will
be further wintry showers around through
the course of the day in the northern
West but elsewhere plenty keep sunshine
and mostly dry again everybody welcome
back to the breakfast show here on Sky
and use the leveling up secretary
Michael Gove has told this program the
government has to balance rewarding hard
work while being careful with public
money he said everyone on the front line
of the NHS is doing a fantastic job but
that the government can't meet every pay
request
I think we appreciate that nurses
everyone who's working on the front line
in the National Health Service is not
only doing an amazing job and my thanks
and gratitude to nurses uh today is
something I want to express very deeply
and personally I also think that when
we're looking at the uh the paid claims
that are being made but by people within
the National Health Service and also
people in other parts of the public
sector we have to balance uh making sure
that we do everything we can to reward
them for their hard work with
recognizing that we also have to be
careful stewards of public money overall
and what we can't do is necessarily
exceed to every demand in the public
sector for pay increases because uh we
don't want to be in a position where the
public finances overall are out of
control
yeah so your colleagues are wrong to
criticize the way nurses manage their
money
I would never criticize uh nurses for uh
uh something like that I think the most
important thing to do is to recognize
the people who are working in the NHS
are people who've dedicated their lives
to a caring profession they're doing
everything they can to support us
as far as with us this morning he wanted
to talk about leveling up which we went
on to talk about of course but
interesting comments about strikes yes
we've got a real spring of strikes now
and we've got not only the nurses on
strike again today but in February we've
got what's being described as the
biggest walkout in the history of the
NHS where you've got nurses on strike
but also ambulance workers both the
paramedics and the call handlers on
strike on the same day and if you think
about the fact that when there were
nurses going on strike in December
around 30 000 elective procedures a day
were canceled if you've got ambulance
call handlers on strike as well you're
looking at some really serious
disruption at hospitals and of course
the prospect of patients and dying while
they're waiting for an ambulance as
kirst armor raised a prime minister's
questions yesterday the politics of this
seems to be that Steve Barkley made
quite a strong argument that the nurses
should be given perhaps a one-off
payment perhaps um their pay for next
year brought forward good he lost that
argument Jeremy Hunt is being very very
tough on pay because the government fear
that if you give one bit of the public
sector a pay increase then there will be
a clamor to give the teachers a pay
increase as well for example
um but the difficulty is that while
Steve Barkley is now urging the nurses
please think about next year's um pay
settlement I'm open to discussing that
one they want to go on strike now over
this year's pay settlement so when
ministers are out trying to talk about
other bits of policy the question
they're going to get is all the public
can see are people going on strike in
vital Services
um he was very reluctant to criticize
nurse's budgeting though wasn't it yeah
we've seen in some of the papers this
morning the former leveling up says true
Simon Clark saying that if nurses earned
37 000 pounds and need a food bank
they're not budgeting properly exactly
and Julian Keegan of course on our
program saying that people go to food
banks for all sorts of personal reasons
like relationship breakdown and I think
they are acutely aware at the top of
government that the polling shows the
public are on the side of nurses going
on strike and understand that someone
earning even slightly above the average
pay 35 to 45
000 the the is the average pay for a
nurse will be struggling with living
costs with energy costs with buying
their children everything they need for
school as everyone else's and I think
Michael Gove is very aware of that okay
well tomorrow's take at nine o'clock I
think our group of MP
calling on the government to appoint a
mental health Czar to be an advocate for
patients they also suggest a new
commissioner could oversee reforms in
the sector it comes as the joint
parliamentary committee scrutinizes the
draft mental health bill
joined Now by The Joint committee's
chair baroness Bosco hi it's good to see
you hi Keith thank you very much for
joining us apologies for my voice oh
Sarah have you had one of those horrible
polls that everybody's had I hope you're
recovering no I'm fine thank you um talk
to us about the draft Bill okay so we
really welcome we being this joint
committee members of the Lords and the
commons and cross party so it's a very
much a Collegiate approach to this we
really support the government's draft
bill which is all about improving
patient Choice Bringing Down the number
of people who are detained and also
making sure that we tackle real racial
inequality that currently exists in the
mental health system
um and but what we want to do as a
committee and we have now uh published a
report
recommending strengthening some of the
uh proposals in the draft bill because
we believe in order for the government
to achieve its aims which are really
good aims and they're backed by so many
people we listen to through taking
evidence from patients through carers
from families is that the whole system
needs to be better resourced it needs to
be therefore carefully implemented in
terms of the timing of when parts of the
bill come become a reality because we
can't have people falling through the
stools and so on and everyone seems to
accept that let's get it absolutely
right
but the person we think that could do
that would be a mental health
commissioner someone who would be able
to have oversight across the country
because provision is disparate across
the country
um to ensure that before people are
released into the community which we
want we really want less restriction and
more patient choice that there are
proper places in the community safe
places where people can go when they're
in a crisis
and where they can be supported properly
supported so it's a big move it's a big
challenge but we believe it's the right
way forward you talk there about
um racial disparity baroness what about
those with autism and learning
difficulties are they looked after well
enough well the difficulty is that too
many of them are being detained in
totally inappropriate settings and this
has been going on for far too long it
has to stop
um people with learning difficulties and
autism may need to be detained for short
periods of time in order to assess
what the problem really is
but we are saying no longer than 28 days
except in exceptional circumstances
because the reality is
these people can be perfectly well
looked after
when they know there's somewhere that
they can go to in the community where
they can have a safe space in order to
cope with their crisis and proper
support as well proper advocacy people
who are actually can say to them you
know how can we help you have a stronger
voice
treat you as an individual because we
want fewer restrictions upon these
people and we want them to be treated as
individuals and respected with dignity
and we must leave it there baroness
thank you very much indeed thank you
very much thank you one aspect as we
were hearing that the committee
considered bear with me one second is
the draft Bill's ability to tackle
racial disparity and how it's interacted
with the criminal justice system joined
Now by chief officer of the Caribbean
and African Health Network Charles
guarco odoi
um hi Charles good to see you
um what difference will this mental
health Bill make for the people that you
represent
good to see you Kate uh I think first
and foremost we need to welcome the bill
and and the recognition of the racial
disparities that we've known about for a
few decades now and and what you know
picking on on the baroness's point we we
delighted this is cross party because
what we need is that long-term
commitment because short-term stuff
wouldn't work and and I think we've seen
the data and we can talk about the data
all day but for for black people more
likely to be detained poorer outcomes
when you look at perinatal mental health
when you look at you know the outcomes
within accused settings so it's quite
complex and I think what we need is that
commitment beyond the bill but then for
you know senior health leaders and
service providers and Commissioners to
put the resource where it is needed one
size wouldn't fit all
okay are you hopeful though I mean
hearing what we've just been hearing
from the baroness and the information
that you've received so far are you
hopeful that this report and the
subsequent
um legislation will tackle racial
disparity issues that obviously uh you
and those that you represent are very
concerned about particularly when it
comes to mental health treatment
yes we're hopeful because if if you look
at what is happening since the pandemic
there has been a real recognition of how
health inequalities are quite deep and
when it comes to marginalized
underserved communities and one of the
priorities for every IC is the 42 across
you know England and Wales is to tackle
Health inequalities so what we're saying
is you know we need to use those
multi-prong approach and the levers that
have been provided followed by the
resources and the you know argument for
long-term investment into this to bring
about the change and I think the other
point with mentioning which the
foreigners refer to is about community
care because sometimes there's a real
divide between acute care and what is
happening in the community and and which
brings into Focus the role of voluntary
sector organizations in tackling the
issues and and moving away from the
medicalized model that is where you know
if we can work right across sectors
making sure that we're resourcing the
world work of voluntary sector
organizations to you know work in
conjunction with acute statutory bodies
then that is when we're going to see a
long-term change
explaining that to us and for joining us
so early in the morning thank you hello
again everybody welcome back to the
breakfast show on Sky News the
government has insisted any change to
NHS pay has to be decided by the
independent pay review body but the
British Medical Association or BMA has
today published a report describing the
independence of the body as a sham the
chair of the BMS Consultants committee
Dr Vishal Sharma is with us now hello
easy doctor thanks so much for indeed
for joining us on the program this
morning
um you've talked about a Litany of
instances of meddling and interference
as far as the government is concerned
you also talk about
wholesale reform of the review body
covering the pay of doctors as well as
dentists as not being resolved and you
go on to talk about the perryview body
being a sham tell us more
yeah so the pair of your bodies were set
up because obviously in the NHS we have
a essentially a monopoly employer so if
you aren't happy with your pay you can't
go around and look for different plugs
terms of condition is all the same but
for for over 10 years the government
have really constrained the pair of your
body so for example between 2010 and
2017 they essentially told the pair of
your body that even though inflation was
running higher that they have either
freeze pay or cap pay Rises to one
percent so they had no power to actually
um do anything about it and the pay
everybody that's supposed to be
independent just went along with that
and in 2018
um as another example that's when the
paving body thought actually this is not
right we will actually recommend a
higher award than the government's limit
of one percent and they recommended two
percent but the government decided that
they weren't going to have that and they
actually essentially reduced it by half
by only paying it for half the year so
when the government's interfering with
with the process like that it can't be
Independence because it's really capping
the amount of recommendations decisions
it can make
yeah I'd put that actually to Robert
generic um yesterday he insisted that
the pay review body is independent he
says of course they have to work within
a budget and of course the Prime
Minister and the ministers involved will
know what that budget cap must be
yeah but the budget is an arbitrary
limit set by government it's not really
a real budget if that makes sense so so
that the government for example are
telling the baby body that um the budget
is set for the next few years at for
example two percent for next year and
they're also saying that they need to
keep in line with the inflation Target
not the actual level of inflation but
the inflation Target again that
inflation Target is two percent but we
all know that inflation's out of control
and it's running at 10 so having these
arbitrary limits because they are you
know they are choices by government it
really means that the paper buddies
can't do their job and be independent
and when they were first set up so they
were first set up following a royal
Commission in the 1960s they were really
interested in only three things making
sure the pay kept up with the cost of
living to make sure that actually kept
it with other comparative professions
and that actually Recruitment and
Retention in the in the medical and
dental Workforce was was on track and
all three of those things it's failed
with
but the funds aren't endless is what the
government would say the treasury will
say potentially to the NHS this is how
much money you can have this year and
then that information distills down to
the pay review body
but again these These are choices the
government since since 2008 has
essentially not been funding the NHS
properly and that's why we're in the
mess that we're in
um and this but that increases costs
when it wants to find money it's very
able to find money is it found huge sums
of money for things like test and Trace
which were a failure at 37 billion
pounds it also finds money when it when
it wants to in other areas and you know
only in the last mini budget for example
it it's lifted caps on Bankers bonuses
there are other things that it chooses
to do but it's choosing to sort of
restrict doctors and dentists pay
but Junior doctors and Consultants I
believe have pulled out of the peer
review process for this year how does
that help
so we've had long-standing concerns
about the peer review process and
actually Juniors and doctors in England
withdrew last year so this isn't a new
thing but what's interesting is a lot of
other unions have actually come to the
same conclusion that actually
participating in this is is not a
helpful process I think the reason we've
withdrawn from this is two reasons first
of all we're demanding that the process
is reformed so we've written very
clearly to the Secretary of State and to
the chair of the ddrb who's our
pay-per-view body and to say this this
cannot go on it needs to be reformed
alongside its founding principles but
also it's it's to not be part of you
know of this um of this sham process
because obviously the government have
really taken to the baby bodies this
year sort of saying they're Bound by
them and they and their independence and
they can't do anything differently we
know that's not true I think by
participating in that we're sort of
essentially giving the government a bit
more of a a line to actually say that
that that's what's that's the process
being used but we just don't have
confidence in it anymore and that's why
we've pulled out
you talk about a Litany of instances of
meddling and interference by the
government do you have examples
yeah so along with those examples I
mentioned um you know where essentially
governments told the pair of your body
what the maximum it can give being
naught or one percent for about eight
years
um only last year uh and the year before
for example that Junior doctors they
agreed a new contract
um a few years ago and as part of that
contract there was a funding envelope
that was kind of agreed for this sort of
contract change but in that contract it
was very very clear that um if there are
exceptional circumstances that the ddrb
can actually make um higher pay uplifts
during that period and there's nothing
more exceptional really than the global
pandemic and the highest inflation for
40 years and yet the government
essentially told the ddrb that they
could not make a recommendation for
junior doctors pay and if you read the
last report it was clear that the ddrb
wanted to make a recommendation and you
know for junior doctors pay that was
higher than their multi-year deal but
they essentially said we'd like to give
a recommendation but were prevented from
doing so by government and again that's
essentially the report from last year so
again it's another example where they're
just essentially doing what they're told
again looking at the report suggesting
that it's becoming more attractive for
GPS to work in another country
it's not not just GPS it's true Junior
doctors it's true of consultants and
it's true of GPS
um the again because there's very little
opportunities to work within medicine
outside the NHS because obviously it's
the Monopoly employer essentially people
are are looking at elsewhere and we are
we are constantly seeing recruitment
companies from overseas trying to take
our doctors to other countries where
they actually do pay much much better
and it's very possible to get paid
that's two or three times higher in
Australia America Canada Etc and people
are going
um and it's a real real problem for us
okay thanks very much indeed thank you
well can the NHS survive We'll be asking
that question during a debate on the
future of our health service next
Thursday the 26th of January scan the QR
code on screen or email nhscrisis at
sky.uk if you'd like to be in the live
audience at University Hospital Coventry
that's a special debate on the future of
the NHS next Thursday seven o'clock here
on Sky News